been getting reports of a drone and
rocket attack on the anal Assad Airbase
that hosts Us and other International
forces in Western Iraq according to the
Reuters news agency multiple blasts were
heard inside the base now the ANL Assad
Air Base is located in the western anbar
Province meanwhile in a separate
incident the US Navy has intercepted
three missiles in the northern Red Sea
the Pentagon says they believe this was
a houthi attack launched from Yemen and
that prel preliminary evidence suggests
that the drones and missiles were
potentially heading towards
Israel the crew of the guided missile
destroyer USS Carney operating in the
northern Red Sea earlier today shot down
three land attack cruise missiles and
several drones that were launched by
houi forces in Yemen this action was a
demonstration of the integrated air and
missile defense architecture that we
have built in the Middle East and that
we are prepared to utilize whenever
necessary to protect our partners and
our interest
in this important region there were no
casualties to US forces and none that we
know of to any civilians on the ground
information about these engagements is
still being processed and we cannot say
for certain what these missiles and
drones were targeting but they were
launched from Yemen heading north along
the Red Sea potentially towards Targets
in Israel well let's speak now to mhmed
Abdul our correspondent there who joins
us from Baghdad mwood I see there are no
details from the Pentagon on what's just
happened
at an Assad what do we know at this
stage well this is the third attack
targeting a US military facility in less
than 24 hours uh on Wednesday two
military bases the Assad this is the
same military base that was targeted
today and Al Military Base which is a a
home to us uh forces in Northern Iraq
were also Al uh targeted uh by uh drones
and missiles now uh military factions
backed by Iran have been uh recently
threatening to uh Target US military
facilities uh in case the United States
continues supporting and backing Israel
on its military campaign against Gaza
now today's attack according to security
sources in the ambar province that's in
Western Iraq will the military bases
located say that several explosions were
heard in front of the Assad military
base it is not known for certain until
as of yet uh whether or not this attack
today's attack has caused damage or
casualties inside Assad military base
which is home to us and the
international uh military personnel as
you know that many political and
military factions in Iraq have been
rising up against the military campaign
by Israel and Gaza threatening to take
matters into their own hands threatening
to uh travel to the borders with uh with
the Jordan and to mobilize there and
also uh threatening to attack uh
military uh us interests in Iraq in case
it continues to support
Israel M ABD on that developing story
for us with the latest thank thank you
Mahmud let's now go to our correspondent
Patty Khan in Washington DC Patty we've
just heard from the Pentagon given what
we've seen over the last week and over
the last few hours no details from them
on that how real though are the fears of
escalation
now uh they're very wor uh worried about
escalation I think that you can see that
in how little they are talking about it
and how few details they are giving
obviously we hearing reports that uh uh
that base in Iraq has been hit multiple
times it didn't even come up at the
briefing The Briefing was delayed by
about 45 minutes so I assumed he was
trying to get information to be able to
relay that but he is giving information
about uh attacks that happened days ago
he said on the 18th in the early morning
uh ours in Syria there about 900 US
troops in Syria that two drones were
sent into the Garrison as he called it
one was destroyed one got in and said it
caused some injuries didn't really go
into detail about how many which is
somewhat unusual for the Pentagon then
talking about those strikes my colleague
was just talking about in Iraq uh two
drones again one destroyed uh one did uh
they were able to damage it but they
said those two cause casualties didn't
explain again again what casualties and
then that other uh base in Iraq so uh
obviously trying to use very tempered
language because this is the concern in
the United States polls show repeatedly
that Americans are paying attention to
what's going on and they are gravely 8
out of 10 concerned that this very
concerned that this could lead to a
broader con uh broader conflict so I
think in the fact that the information
is not necessarily coming out quickly
and that they're giving very little
detail shows just how much they want to
be able to send the message that the US
is not getting involved although I have
to say shooting down missiles uh from
Yemen highly unusual move for the
Pentagon and when asked why they did
that what was the justification he
really couldn't answer it uh Patty I'm
curious about this because as you say
there hasn't been a great deal of
information sharing this isn't the first
attack this week on NL Assad I'm I'm
wondering what we should make of what
looks like an escalation I know he was
asked about whether or not they were
taking additional measures to keep their
staff safe is there a growing concern
that that something might have to change
in terms of us
presence I think the growing concern is
going to be that these drones are
actually causing injuries you know they
they've had um they for 20 years in Iraq
they set up all of these different
systems to be able to knock things down
out of the air I was there I could see
like the like a Howitzer sort of thing
fires multiple multiple bullets per
second um but the fact that the air
warning system sounded and in both cases
one drone was damaged and caused
injuries and another the Drone got
through and caused injuries so obviously
the concern is going to be can they
actually Pro protect their troops in the
region cuz that would lead to a broader
conflict if a lot of Americans are
killed then you could easily see how
this could escalate so I think one of
the questions they're going to be asking
in the Pentagon is how did this happen
because obviously they've invested a lot
of money on air defense systems in both
Iraq and Syria Pat C Haan there with the
latest for us from Washington DC after
that Pentagon press conference thank you
Patty